YOU VERYH.
PRESIDENF STATES MIKEE WITH
ANVE TO BEGIN
EST OF FON VERY MUC
JOINING USRULYTANT DAYN T GRAND
NOWY, AS YOU WELL KNOW, AS AL
RELY DEVELOPMENT.TOBEALLY CHARG.
I WANT TO GET YOUR REACTION
THIS UREELLL T
INDICTME FORMER PRESIDENT OF
. BUT IT WASN'T JUST MRLLIONS ON
PRESIDE. EX M
.  THE
PROSECUT
ATRN NEW YORKO  WAS A GRAND JURI
N LAWD AND BEEN
THE OLD
YIOU CANTH THOEURPROOF  MAKE DEM
FEDERAL PROCUTO ON
THISHETTAN D INITIALLY
SED ON IT
ENOUAVTTORNEY
GENERAL IN NEW YORK AND
AMERI IN THEIR
CAMPAIGNSTHINKENTHE NOTION  TLMG
THE AMERICAN. PEOPLE
O  IN FAIRNE
BELIEVE INALAW, AND THIS APPEARS
JUSTICE SYSTEM THATTIERED
PEOPLE HAVE HAD ENOUGH OOUR
STPAMEPENCEARTMENT
WELL KWTHEY CHARGEDMPFORMERICHA,
UHY SAME SAID  THEM
M  NTMENT IN
YOU CONCEDE? TH CN SEE THE LYINH
IF MORYS TH J FOR THE MOST
T. I HAVE TO
PROCESS OF MAKING DECISIONS
YOU KNOW,
THAT. K I
CITIES. AND EVEN THGH THIS
NR THE LAST
AND ISSUESE
AND ANOTHER I NEWS, NOT ONE PERI
TELL
THESE
INIGONALD TRUMPTHINK IT'S BEINGF
THE FAIL OF THE RATIONS. BUTHIS
TH I THINK I THINK THE GOING TON
IMLVE T IN ORDE P CONVI OF THISE
REPUBLICANSIINEEULDF HE'STED? IT
APA POSSTHAT A JUDOU BEFORE WE O
T I DON'TT TOTI
YOU
ABOUISN
ST FAILE OF THE BIDEN
, OM AND
ROPE FORUM
CUSESETHE N
CONVSAAYS BEGUN
THE FUTUREER
NEVERE , I
HOLY HAVELL YOUHA I
THIS IS O I
E STRUGGLING THAT THIS WILL ONLY
VED TO DIVIDE OU WOLF. YOU KNOW,
YOU'REOU
WOULD HAVE TNHATTAN DTHERI ABOAN
D PUTHE INTES THE
FIRST, BUT LET'T'S
PUT NTO SOMEORRSPECTIVE. AS YOU
AL DEATH ANDDESTRUIOACES BOR YOE
POTE FORLENCEND
THE 6TH
THERE'S NO KIND ONTHIS DEBATEHEG
CARE OF HIMSELF IN THE COURTROOM
AND HE OUGHT TO
RIGHT GOTOU IS THIS IGOO
AG YOU AGREE, THOUGH
S GEOUSAGSIDE O THIS IS UEP
THATANT TO SAY
TO Y RBEEVEC IS A GREAT
DISSERVICE TO THE COUNTRY ANDFOE
A FENT WOULD BICN A
CAGNAN, IT
JUST SMACKS OF POLITICALPROSECUT
C IN WHICH
YOU WOULD THINK IT WOULD BEAPPRY
CATEGORICALLYLMINALNO ONE
VE THEINSIDENTON TOI AND THE AMN
PEOPLE KNOW THIS THIS
CA A CONTROVERSY
CA,
TO THE MAREL. BUT I
L T ANDAND HISTORICRENCE H TO TE
FFCOHEN,
WHONGCHAELEN
LOOK THIS IS
MAKEHE DSE, ANTORS
PEOPLE OF GRIN
INDICTMENT TODAYNG ALLALOR, ANDI
HAS NO BEARING ON OUR DECISIONON
CAG GOING TO
CONTINUE TO TRELE
UND AND
T OOU AND
CONGRESS MYOR OFITHE
ADMINISTRATION WHILE IT DI, I'LD
OF T